el último día de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio los mejores atletas del planeta
compitieron en una edición sui generis
marcada por la pandemia de kobe 19 tras
el final del evento los organizadores de
los olímpicos informaron que en total 19
atletas no participaron al haber dado
positivo en los premios de coronavirus
con su crimen ahora tiritona porque está
me gustaría elogiar firmemente los
logros previos a los juegos de tokio de
estos 19 atletas astrid o no desde el
fondo de mi corazón les deseo lo mejor
en su carrera como deportistas en el
futuro quiero agradecerle a todos por
haber venido a japón muchas gracias
el número de contagios porque hoy 19
acumulados entre todas las personas
participantes en los olímpicos de tokio
fue de 430 personas tras sumarse 26
nuevos contagios el mismo día en que se
clausuró el evento
ahora que tokio se prepara para los
juegos paralímpicos que inician el
próximo 24 de agosto cuál es la
sensación que le ha dejado este evento a
los japoneses
estaba un poco preocupado pero al final
los juegos olímpicos' alegraron a japón
y al mundo
[Música]
después de la inauguración las nuevas
infecciones aumentaron por eso trato de
ser muy cuidadosa
este domingo los casos por correo en el
virus en tokio alcanzaron un récord por
cuarto día consecutivo con más de 15 mil
700 casos reportados el sábado
diferentes variantes del virus han
circulado en los últimos días en la
capital nipona y la propagación de dell
está altamente contagiosa se intensifica
en el país el gobierno mantendrá el
estado de emergencia por lo menos hasta
el comienzo de los paralímpicos y más
regiones se han sumado a la medida para
controlar la pandemia de kobe 19